obviously you are
uh part of the huge amazon series lord
of the rings
um uh what was it like did you go after
that role did they ask you
how did it come happen for you well
um it was a long audition process
and then i kind of didn't
hear from them for a few months i mean
the the whole world
was struggling to figure out what we
were going to do next at that point
and then one of the show runners
jd um called me
and he pitched the part and and pitched
the commitment which is
large and i could hear on the phone
that there was a pa system and a lot of
noise in the background
and uh i still wasn't sure and i said jd
where
where are you he said i'm in the
hospital i said are you okay he said no
my wife's having a baby
and he's calling me to
pitch a job to me and
um while he's having a kid and i just
thought well
he's got the level of commitment you're
going to need to get this show to be
where it should be
it would be a huge mistake to not take
part
i am so looking forward to this series
and everyone has heard
that amazon is investing a ton of money
to make this the best it could possibly
be
as someone who is obviously working on
it on the inside does it feel that way
as you're filming that you guys are
making something
huge yeah i mean there is a lot of talk
about the money but i
i kind of feel like that's what you need
to do it right
um it's like if you you found someone
you're in love with you want to buy them
a ring you're going to
do the best you can to show that you're
committed to it
and it's not unlike that
that this is not a legendarium that you
want to skimp on
oh no 100 also the the world is going to
tune in for this thing
this is like a i mean this is something
that a lot of people
um well anyway enough about that i know
i don't want to get you in any trouble
but
what can you actually say about your
character in the series or are you sort
of on
like full lockdown with that kind of
information
the green light on my zoom call just
started to throb
they're listening um
i i really can't say a lot
and and here's the thing it's usually
annoying
when they tell you not to talk about it
you know
here's what you can't say here's what
you can't say and um
on this one i kind of agree with them
they're
because there's so much attention and
because so much
happens um it's important that we do
protect it so i really can't say a lot
other than you will be glad
you knew so little when you see it yeah
i actually am one of those people that i
don't want to know spoilers
before i see it i want to be surprised
every week
i'm completely on board with the with
that
but at the same time for you as an as an
actor look
i know i love new zealand and i would
love to spend time down there
is it was it a little bit um you know
because
again i don't know if you you might last
a season you might last all five seasons
i i don't know what your thing is
but is it weird to sign on to something
that could be
um multiple years
yes that is weird
um but again with tolkien i
mean i was a huge fan as a kid and and
um
as and still am as an adult and uh
it was kind of one of those where if you
say no you might regret it for the rest
of your life
it comes out and you go i could have
been doing that
right no no completely um well i will
say uh because i'm just about out of
time are you
are you done soon are you leaving like
uh is this one going
to be something that you are there for
like uh you know for the rest of the
year
like how how does it work in terms of
what you get to do with other projects
oh you're asking all the right questions
none of which i have answers to
it it is a bit uh nebulous at this
point um uh we've been here a long time
and they'll let us go when they're done
with us
it's kind of like that